[Music]
it's time to look forward throughout
2020 and see what PlayStation gamers can
expect to have their wallets completely
emptied by over the next 12 months if
you are new to this annual video the
rules are simple I may only include
PlayStation exclusive and console
exclusive titles or timed exclusives for
PlayStation so I cannot talk about the
brilliant cyberpunk or the mesmeric
resident evil 3 all the upcoming
Marvel's Avengers or the excellent yeah
you get the idea in this video it's all
about the ps4 this is a huge year for
PlayStation gamers ending with an entire
new console generation the holy PS 5 but
let's not waste our year waiting for the
future let's check out 10 PlayStation
exclusives you need to play in 2020 be
sure to comment what you are looking
forward to I'll be in the comments
lurking
yeah I'm starting with the last of us
apart too easily my most anticipated
game of 2020 which so happened to be a
ps4 exclusive Ellie and Joel returned
from the zombie fuelled nightmare
surviving the Katis EPS virus and
quickly realizing humans remain the real
enemy even in the post-apocalyptic world
Ellie has now matured into a young woman
trying to figure out the same things we
all go through like girlfriends military
training fighting clickers and surrogate
dad issues ok maybe not like most of us
but this is where the brilliance of the
developer Naughty Dog comes through the
storytelling takes center stage with
exquisite voice acting and mocap making
the narrative hit you right in the
fields on the gameplay side part two
brings in new mechanics like going prone
and hiding under vehicles or in tall
grass and there are dogs here now too
the cute little buggers will hunt you
down using your smell and alert all
enemies to your position the last of us
has evolved and on May 29 2020 we can
finally see what happens to our beloved
Ellie and Joel another gargantuan ps4
exclusive is the ghost of Tsushima from
sucker punch those are the guys who
brought you Sly Cooper
the infamous series they've now turned
their attention to feudal Japan gifting
us an action and stealth adventure to
battle through if you can't already tell
by the footage we are a samurai in a
fully open world there's talk of the
on-screen herd been taken away
completely to fully immerse as when
exploring in a way to stop players
endlessly following a mini-map or
sat-nav to different locations we have
to learn the world of ghosts of Tsushima
we have to learn the locations of
Tsushima Island look how bloody
beautiful it is though I was convinced
this would be a ps5 exclusive but he'll
know it's coming to ps4 in the summer of
2020 here's the premise after our people
were brutally slayed by our enemy we
pick up our katana as The Last Samurai
and devolve our fighting style to offend
our comrades and take down the Mongol
invaders
I'll break this down fully near at the
time but just for now let's just look at
the leaves one more time wow I never
thought I'd been pressed by leave
physics but I am these soon ghosts of
Tsushima
[Music]
back in 2017
neo was a quiet PlayStation exclusive
that grew into one of the most respected
games on the platform playing very much
like a souls bond game but with a
samurai inspired story and location
it was almost Sakura before Sakura
existed neo 2 comes back with a prequel
not a sequel meaning this happened three
hundred years before neo allowing us to
play them in any order we like games
like this are made for the hardcore the
extensive exploration the intense
fighting styles and counters and blocks
so it's called the fighting intricate to
say the least and oh yeah you will die
you will die often neo 2 will be
difficult if you played the original
you'll understand and if you did play
neo you should know that the character
customization the weapons the fighting
depth have all been improved deep and
expanded you're gonna love this or in my
case you're gonna love to hate this so
if you want an action-packed hack and
slash role-playing game with a
difficulty curve to suit neo to is your
jam releasing on march 13th 2020 the
games keep coming all year-round and one
of them has to be a remake right but
this isn't just any remake this is Final
Fantasy 7 remake the OG PlayStation 1
game has been rebooted both visually and
mechanically with real time combat
replacing turn-based strategy of the 90s
but the story remains intact with all
the cinematics you'd expect from a 2020
video game in fact the story has been
deepened with smaller sections of the
1997 game expanded to add to the law and
narrative of Final Fantasy and look how
beautiful it is even the gruff mr. t
inspired Barrett looks good enough to
eat your dinner off hang on this is
joking there somewhere all right let's
just move on the entire cast returns to
pull at your heartstrings once again and
if this is your first Final Fantasy game
you are in for a real treat
taking on Shinra who are draining the
planet's life energy so let out your
inner eco warrior and beat the crap out
of the establishment
beretta thumb burg would be proud of you
Final Fantasy 7 remake will be taking
over the internet on March 3rd 2020 with
other platforms getting the game about a
year later another PlayStation console
exclusive is predator hunting grounds an
asymmetric survival title in which one
person plays the predator
and takes on numerous players who are
militarized badasses if you played the
ill-fated evolve or dead by daylight or
my personal favorites
Friday the 13th you have a clear
understanding of the premise here but
predator hunting grounds evolves this
basis up to four players are tasked with
real objectives against AI bad guys such
as storming a rebel village with tons of
weapons to claim a MacGuffin but this is
the point the whole thing is thrown
sideways with the introduction of the
predator they may be solo but they have
abilities - more than even the
battlefield see this as teamwork and
coordination against stealth and
overpowered sci-fi skills expect this to
be as tense as the other games in this
genre but different enough to forge its
own path I have to say visually this
isn't looking good enough at the moment
for me and the license is using but
there is plenty of time to polish the
visuals before predator hunting ground
arrives on ps4 and PC this time on April
24th so what about psvr the headset has
been supported by many games over the
years such as the sublime Astro bot and
my personal favorites blood and truth
well in 2020 psvr will receive its own
exclusive Ironman game inspirationally
titled
Ironman VR surely this is what we are
needs a shooter and flying simulator
which is guaranteed to make me vomit -
from travel sickness I cannot wait to
play this we play as Tony Stark
going about his daily activities
fighting bad guys and wrongdoers in a
bright-red cyber suit the heads-up
display looks like those seen in the
movies and flying is said to be uncanny
with the thrusters in the palm of your
hands the story sees Tony revisited by a
ghost of his past from his days as an
arms dealer giving fans an in-depth
narrative and backstory to uncover and
enjoy some like your kinda game Ironman
VR hits the PlayStation 4 on February 28
2020
for years now I feel like I've been
talking about dreams a game about
creating other games basically a suite
of tools to design and build developed
by those guys behind Sackboy and
LittleBigPlanet the formula has changed
and evolved dreams is about creating
anything you can dream up I guess that
explains the title I've been keeping an
eye on this for many years now and I've
seen such a breadth of games which are
possible here someone created the horror
corridor from Silent Hill PT another
person made a playable Sonic the
Hedgehog game from the Dreamcast era so
basically I'm saying this game could be
1 million games in one place Dreamz
looks to become a community of creators
who build and improve together from jump
scares to platformers from racing Sims
to arcade sports titles the potential of
dreams is are inspiring and they're also
going to add psvr support too so look
out for this On February 14th 2020
[Music]
the persona audience is humongous the
Japanese RPG series is on many people's
best games lists and multiple RPGs of
the decade in March 2020 persona 5 royal
releases if you aren't hugely into the
series and feel like you've heard that
title before your rights back in 2016
persona 5 drops and royal is an expanded
version featuring tons of new content
Japan had this game back in October but
the Western release was pushed to March
2020 the game revolves around a high
school student with the codename Joker
and runs through one year of time in a
day-night cycle what's impressive about
persona games are the social construct
the social simulations in which time of
day weather and story beats all impact
interactions with NPCs resulting in
branching paths of the story the ending
you receive may be completely different
from your friend which pulls players
back into play once again replayability
is a godsend
the royal version of personify features
an additional phantom thief named Kasumi
a new palace new music additional plot
points and social elements a playable
third semester to get through and I
gotta admit I am tempted to get into
persona after looking at this game March
31st 2020 if you're interested my final
pick is a strange one it's a game we
talked about a year ago wild an
exclusive ps4 game which vanished into
obscurity seen as a truly open-world set
in the prehistoric history of mankind
basically we'll play as a caveman but we
have some supernatural powers we've seen
a Shaymin character who can control the
mind of an eagle to scout the terrain
and even call bears as a mode of
transport these spirit animals were
going to be a key part of wild but then
everything fell silent since then we've
seen games like rust and ancestors the
humankind Odyssey produced games with a
similar feeling of survival but then
late last year the devs behind the game
began to expand their offices causing me
to keep an eye on them and guess what
they renewed the wild license and I have
a sneaking suspicion Wilde will release
on PS 5 I can't prove that but the signs
that the game is not dead is good enough
for me if I'm honest I just want to
animal hopefully a warthog or do you
think will we ever see wild in the wild
I'd love to know your thoughts so the
year will end with the ps5 being a real
life thing and to commemorate the first
game confirmed for the next generation
here it is
God fall at the moment God fall is
confirmed as a ps4 console exclusive and
via the epic star on PC but let's not
treat that as gospel just yet just look
at it though look at the shiny graphics
touted as a looter slasher in third
person for up to three players to play
cooperatively I like the tagline it's
time for the wolves of war to awaken in
this new RPG we'll have to wait and see
what this becomes but the PS 5 is sure
to have more exclusives in 2020 and
we'll be back at the end of the year for
2020 ones offerings I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade have a great 2020
this is your year I'll see you soon
fellow PlayStation gamers peace out
[Music]